ottawa has been outsourcing its visa
application process for more than a
decade from a few centers in india in
2007 to today with more than 160
processing centers in more than 100
countries around the world
they are all run by a for-profit company
called vfs global it is headquartered in
dubai but it's owned by a swedish
investment firm its current contract
with canada is worth more than 300
million dollars and it has similar visa
processing contracts with dozens of
other countries so when you actually
look at the impact on the system it
allows us to
potentially welcome thousands and
thousands of more people to canada than
otherwise would be the case but the
ukraine crisis has opened up some cracks
in the outsourcing system canada relies
on with complaints about service levels
long lineups and delays conservative mp
jazran hallan toured a vfs global center
during a recent trip to europe i saw the
system there myself i was a little bit
underwhelmed at how much better canada
can be doing today but immigration
minister sean fraser says the
humanitarian crisis like the one in
ukraine is proving the worth of canada's
decision to outsource last month vfs
global opened up what it called pop-up
visa processing centers on ukraine's
border to deal with the surge of
applicants on behalf of its clients
including canada and when you have the
opportunity to use either pop-up or
existing visa application centers in
addition to permanent locations uh for
uh for local missions uh you really can
respond to humanitarian crises more
effectively ndp immigration critic jenny
kwan has long worried about the privacy
implications for those who used
outsourced visa application centers well
to be very honest with you i don't like
the idea at all
with visa application centers there's a
lot of sensitive information that goes
out our main concern is that we should
be bringing things back to canada then
bringing back more to home and have more
control over of course given the rise of
cyber security but it looks like ottawa
is going in the opposite direction the
government is looking at plans to boost
its reliance on these outsourced visa
application centers and increase the
services they provide
david aiken global news ottawa